But the other way of doing 3D sensing is
what we refer to as active 3D sensing,
where somehow, you're projecting
something out into the environment,
or sending some energy
into the environment and
reading that energy back,
in order to recover depth.
So we actually talked just a little
bit about photometric stereo,
when we talked about photometry, and
the idea that you could recover shape
if you had known light sources.
So, even though these are thought
of as regular images, you're,
it's actually an active
sensing technique,
because you're lighting the system in
a controlled way that you know about.
But, when most people talk
about active sensing,
they talk about something that creates,
sort of, special signals or pictures.
So an obvious one is,
just bounce something off a surface,
and wait to see how long it
takes to get back, all right?
So there are different
methods of doing that.
This is a little guy.
He has these little ultrasonic sensors,
okay?
If you go way back in time, back in the,
way back machine, I don't know if
it was the 70s or 80s, the Polaroid
cameras started doing active sensing.
They actually had a little
acoustic sonar chip on them,
that would send out
what's called a chirp.
And then,
based upon how long the response got,
how long the response took,
it knew based upon the speed of sound,
how far away the thing was,
and it would focus the camera.
One of the interesting effects of that
is, because they made so many of those
cameras, it made those sonar things very
cheap, so people started putting them
all over robots and things like that,
and using sonar to detect depth.
Much more sophisticated is what's
called LIDAR, or a Laser Range finder.
There's two of them here.
One is on the side over here,
one is stuck in here.
These are on a PR2 robot.
These actually generate a slice and
they, they send a little beam out and
they wait to see how long it comes back.
Now of course, that's a lot
faster than with sound, okay, but
it, it's measurable, but
you only get a slice of depth.
So then what you actually do, is you put
it on a little device that goes up and
down like that, and so this little front
area actually sweeps that plane and
it produces a 3D depth image that way.
So that's these are referred
to as time of flight sensors.